how do you define freedom
stop for a minute and picture what it
means to be free what comes into your
mind traveling wherever you please
having enough money to do what you want
or is freedom better defined by what
it's not not having anyone telling you
what to do not being in prison freedom
is a core aspect of us national identity
but if someone gave you a box labeled
contents freedom what would you expect
to find inside this was the question
that the united states faced during
reconstruction the period following the
civil war when the u.s government
southern state governments and african
americans attempted to negotiate a new
social and political order for the south
but what african americans expected to
find in the box labeled freedom was very
different from what their former
enslavers wanted to put there was
freedom just the absence of slavery as
most white southerners believed or did
it imply citizenship political power and
economic self-sufficiency trying to
solve this dilemma congress passed and
the states ratified three new
constitutional amendments during the
reconstruction era the 13th amendment
which ended the system of slavery in
1865 the 14th amendment which extended
citizenship to all persons born or
naturalized in the united states in 1868
and the 15th amendment which gave black
men the right to vote in 1870 so in just
five years african americans in the
south went from personal property to
full civic participants at least in
theory in reality how different were
definitions of freedom citizenship and
democracy before and after
reconstruction to really answer this
question we need to examine continuity
and change in the reconstruction era
what stayed the same and what changed in
each of these three areas following the
passage of the reconstruction amendments
okay first let's look at continuities
and changes in the definition of freedom
before the end of slavery african
americans had neither economic nor
physical freedom they didn't have
control of their bodies or of their
labor the past system kept them from
moving freely and slavery itself meant
that they couldn't choose where to work
or earn money from their own work so how
much did their physical and economic
freedom change after the 13th amendment
outlawed slavery while their economic
self-sufficiency went through some ups
and downs most african americans
believed that their years of unpaid toil
entitled them to land of their own u.s
army general william tecumseh's sherman
redistributed confederate territory on
the coasts of georgia and south carolina
to black families who farmed there for a
few years until lincoln's successor
andrew johnson gave all confiscated land
back to its former owners instead most
black farmers became sharecroppers
renting a portion of a white landowner's
farm in exchange for part of the crop
yield this gave black farmers a lot more
freedom over their own work since they
didn't have to work under an overseer
but economically sharecropping kept
black farmers as well as small white
farmers in an endless cycle of debt and
poverty after the 13th amendment most
southern state governments attempted to
limit the physical freedom of african
americans as well with statutes known as
the black codes many of these codes
defined anyone who wasn't under a labor
contract as a vagrant who could be
arrested and have their labor sold later
segregation limited the physical freedom
of where southern african americans
could go and what they could do laws
like the black codes which so obviously
attempted to institute slavery by
another name led congress to pass the
14th amendment which defined a u.s
citizen as anyone born or naturalized in
the united states and specifically
prevented states from infringing upon
the rights of citizens before the civil
war citizenship was exclusively the
privilege of white americans non-white
immigrants weren't eligible to become
u.s citizens and the 1857 supreme court
decision in dred scott declared that no
african americans could be citizens at
all the 14th amendment ratified in 1868
led to a huge increase in the number of
u.s citizens and it decoupled
citizenship from whiteness even the
american-born children of asian
immigrants were citizens but the supreme
court defined the 14th amendment very
narrowly in the late 19th century
permitting many laws that discriminated
on the basis of race only in the 20th
century would the 14th amendment become
an important tool for civil rights
activists to break down segregation
lastly the 15th amendment ratified in
1870 extended the right to vote to black
men in the years leading up to the civil
war with few exceptions only white men
had the right to vote the 15th amendment
radically redefined the terms of
american democracy during reconstruction
more than 2 000 african americans held
public office including two u.s senators
but there were limits to this new
broader definition of democracy first it
didn't include women much to the
frustration of the women's suffrage
movement then as the federal government
ceased to intervene to protect black
citizens in the south in the late 1870s
southern state governments imposed a
range of voter suppression tactics to
effectively bar african americans from
voting which then reduced the likelihood
of black politicians winning office not
until the 1960s would african-american
voter registration once again reach
reconstruction era levels so how much
did the reconstruction amendments change
definitions of freedom citizenship and
democracy well after the amendments
african americans were free to own their
own bodies and labor but that was about
it the 14th and 15th amendments led to
short-lived revolutions in the concept
of citizenship and in voting rights but
those rights had all but evaporated by
the end of the century nevertheless
although they didn't have much of an
impact in the short term these
amendments would lay the foundation for
the civil rights movement of the 1950s
and 60s